au 16ème siècle on avait déjà eu l'idée
de capter les eaux de l'ourcq pour
relier la marne à la scène l'idée a
couvé pendant trois siècles
et puis le 23 décembre 1825 il y à 152
ans naissait le canal saint martin de la
place de stalingrad au bassin de
l'arsenal un tracé de 4500 mètres dont
1800 mètres souterrain le canal est
couvert entre la place de la république
et celle de la bastille ce projet avait
été proposé par le baron haussmann lui
même des travaux de couverture avait
duré de 1857 à 1906 près de cinquante
ans
non
je
ah oui
il y a encore des péniche sur le canal
saint martin mais de moins en moins en
moyenne six par jour
on y transporte trois fois moins de
marchandises qu'il y a dix ans il faut
dire que le canal saint martin est le
seul des trois canaux parisiens à
n'avoir subi aucune modification de
gabarit
son accès est limité aux embarcations à
ces petites 40 mètre soixante dix de
long sept mètres 70 de large 1 mètre 90
d'enfoncement charge limitée à 250
tonnes environ
alors que sur la scène on trouve des
convois de 5000 tonnes
oh
ce
le canal saint martin est en outre
équipé de 16 écluses et les bateaux vont
plus vite
en parcourant la boucle de la seine
qu'en remontant ses écluses donc un
canal âgées aux dimensions limites et
que l'on ne peut pas tellement
moderniser pour la navigation
faux
non
le canal saint-martin et souterrains
entre la place de la république et la
place de la bastille sur 1 km 800 il
n'ya le passage que pour une péniche
e
le
en
enfin
oh
le site du canal saint-martin est
exceptionnel peut-être ce qu'il y à de
plus grandes dimensions à paris après la
scène et les champs elysées
mais l'environnement est parfois gâché
par dv rue des pignons agressif des
constructions vétustes ou même des
immeubles récents qui pousse de façon
anarchique et brutale
et surtout milija la voiture
l'auto qui circulent et qui polluent
l'auto qui stationnent n'importe où et
qui gênent il y a aussi les camions
nombreux dans ce secteur
le paysage en souffrent
il
dans les années 60 on a eu l'idée de
créer un grand axe autoroutier nord-sud
sur le lit du canal asséché
le projet a été abandonné en 1971 par le
conseil de paris
en novembre 1973 l'atelier parisien
d'urbanisme la pure s'est vu confier une
étude sur le canal saint martin et ses
abords
résultat de ces travaux d'étude le 1er
octobre 1974
michel guy de secrétaire d'état à la
culture annonçait officiellement de
classement du canal et de son site
je
il existe aujourd'hui un plan
d'urbanisme pour ce canal et son site
classé que va-t-on faire et bien un
priorité sera donnée aux espaces verts
aux piétons aux loisirs
les bulldozer sont entrés en action
la zac de la grange aux belles et de
l'îlot valmy et verdun sont mises à nu
les entrepôts vétustes les hangars
délabré sont mises à terre
sur les berges du canal
les aménagements viennent de commencer
les espaces verts vont petit à petit
chasser des voitures du quai de valmy
première manche gagnée par l'écologie
un nouveau quartier doit sortir de terre
bientôt on peut déjà rêver à ce que
pourrait être demain
paris / rourke
oh
vous